ينضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور خليل
العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه دكتور خليل نقارن بين المواقف
الامريكيه والمواقف الاسرائيليه في
الساعات الاخيره الجانب الاسرائيلي يتحدث
عن سلطه امنيه على قطاع غزه بعد القضاء
على حماس الجانب الاسرائيلي بينما يقول
الجانب الامريكي بانه
يرفض اي احتلال من قبل اسرائيل لقطاع غ
كيف نقرا هذه المواقف وما حجم التباين ان
كان موجودا انا اعتقد فداء الاختلاف ياتي
من خلال الخبره الامريكيه في حالتي
العراقه افغانستان بنتكلم على تورط امريكي
لمده 20 سنه لم يكن على الاطلاق تجربه
جيده وتم الخروج منها بشكل لحد بعيد فوضوي
في حاله افغانستان وبالتالي هناك حرص
امريكي على عدم تورط اسرائيل في احتلال
قطاع غازه مره اخرى وقرانا منذ اول يوم
لهذه الحرب كانت هناك مقابله لبايدن يتحدث
فيها بشكل صريح ويحذر اسرائيل من من
التورد في احتال قطاع غزه في المقابل
لدينا على ما يبدو بدايه تصور اسرائيلي
متعلق بانه جزء رئيسي من عدم تكرار ما حدث
في الس من اكتوبر ان يتم مره اخرى اعاده
احتلال قطاع غزه كي يضمنوا عدم وجود تهديد
امني على مستط مستوطنات شمال او غلاف غزه
التحدي هنا عده امور الامر الاول هناك
افتراض على ما يبدو الى حد ما غير صحيح
يقول انه في حاله التخلص من حماس لن تكون
هناك مقاومه فلسطينيه وهذا غير طبيعي
طالما في طالما في الاحتلال هناك بالتاكيد
مقاومه الامر الاخر متعلق بالاداره
السياسيه للقطاع بعد لو افترضنا التخلص من
الحماس حدث بالفعل من سيدير القطاع هل
بنتكلم على وجود امن اسرائيلي كثيف هل
بنتكلم على وجود امن اسرائيلي قليل هل
بنتكلم على وجود اممي هل وجود عربي وانا
اعتقد جزء رئيسي من الخلاف لداخل اسرائيل
نفسه مرتبط بالصراع السياسي داخل اسرائيل
بنتكلم على مج مجموعه من الزعماء نتكلم
على نتنياهو يائير لابيد
جالانت كل واحد عنده مشروع سياسي خاص به
ولذلك هناك حتى اختلاف بينهم حول شكل
التواجد الامني في غزه بعد هنالك رؤيه
امريكيه واضحه يعني المتحدث باسم البيت
الابيض اشار الى انه يتم التحضير لمرحله
ما بعد القضاء على حماس ولكن هل تبدو
معالم الرؤيه الامريكيه واضحه
لهذه الفتره ان حصلت لا غير موجود رؤيه
امريكيه واضحه او متماسكه لدينا رؤى غير
ناضجه وتم التعبير عنها خلال الفتره
الماضيه تحدث عنها بلينك عندما جاء
للمنطقه العربيه قال ان هناك اكثر من
سيناريو سيناريو اولي اولي متعلق بامكانيه
اعاده السلطه الفلسطينيه مره اخرى لاداره
القطاع وهذا يعتبر سيناريو لحد بعيد غير
واقعي لماذا السلطه نفسها غير قادره على
اداره الضفه الغربيه هناك مشاكل كثيره جدا
ثانيا السلطه نفسها ما عندهاش شرعيه ولا
رضا مجتمعي ولا رضا سياسي في قطاع غزه
الامر الثاني هناك الطرح لما يطلق عليه
وجود قوه عربيه على الارض تقوم بحفظ الامن
هذا طبعا في تصوري غير واقعي وغير منطقي
نتيجه لوجود خبرات عربيه سيئه الامر
الثالث هناك طرح فيما يتعلق بامكانيه وضع
قوات امميه على غرار اليونيفيل اللي
موجوده ما بين جنوب لبنان وشمال قطاع غزه
وشمال اسرائيل عفوا وبالتالي هناك تصورات
غير ناضجه حتى هذه اللحظه وبالتالي من
الصعب نتكلم عن رؤيه امريكيه متمسكه فيما
تعلق بمستقبل قطاع غزه بعد حماس بين قوسين
طيب اعود معك الى ما قاله كبير مستشاري
نتنياهو للسي ان ان قال علينا التمييز بين
الوجود الامني والسيطره السياسيه في غزه
بعد هذ حماس هل هذه رساله للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه انه نحن لا نتحدث عن
اعاده السيطره نحن نتحدث عن سيطره امنيه
الا حد بعيد كلامك صحيح يا فده ده فعلا
مرتبط بمحاوله اثار الرساله لامريكا انحن
لا نتحدث عن احتلال مره اخرى بنتكلم على
اداره امنيه جزء منه متعلق بوضع امني جديد
يناسب عدم تكرار تكرار هجمات 7 اكتوبر لكن
ايضا كما قلت اكثر من مره ليس هناك حتى
رؤيه امنيه واضحه من سيحفظ الامن في قطاع
غزه لو بنتكلم على وجود اسرائيلي بنتكلم
على استمرار لما يطلق عليه اتريش ور حرب
استنزاف نتيجه لوجود يعني اكيد مقاومه
فلسطينيه يعني صب صعب نتصور ان هناك
احتلال وهناك موت للمقام الفلسطينيه لم
تكن حماس فستكون غيرها بلا شك يبقى
الدعوات تتكرر من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وكان اخرها منذ يعني نصف ساعه
تقريبا كان هنالك عاجل على شاشه فيما
يتعلق
بالهدنيا الجانب الاسرائيلي الى حد الان
يرفض من يؤثر بمن من له القدره على
التاثير بمن الولايات المتحده تنصع ام
تؤثر في اسرائيل هذا سؤال مهم جدا في ده
في هذه الازمه راينا الايه معكوسه تماما
في العادي والطبيعي بنتكلم على قوه عظمى
تؤثر على قوه صغرى او على دوله حليفه لها
في هذه الحرب انا قلت اكثر من مره نحن
اذاء حاله اختطاف من قبل اسرائيل لاداره
بايدن نعم هناك قناعه ان اداره بايدن
اداره ضعيفه مرتعشه غير مؤثره وغير ضاغطه
على اسرائيل شكرا لك دكتور خليل العناني
استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
كنت معنا هنا في الاستديو